the 6 we trap the Trap is when you look
at your calendar 6 weeks from now see
all the blank space and think I could
totally say yes to this as the weeks
count down the space that was empty 6
weeks ago starts to look more and more
full by the time the day itself comes
around you realized you really shouldn't
have said yes to the commitment but
you've done it now and you don't want to
disappoint people by rening every time
you're presented with a request for a
few weeks time think would I be excited
about this Commitment if it was
happening tomorrow or am I only thinking
about saying yes to it because it's
easier to make it a problem for My
Future Self it's so tempting to think 6
weeks from now my schedule is going to
be totally clear so I'll definitely have
time and energy to do this thing you
won't in 6 weeks your life is going to
be just as busy as it is today if you
wouldn't say yes to something happening
tomorrow you shouldn't say yes to it in
a month or more